qué es un algoritmo una definición
podría ser un conjunto de pasos para
realizar una tarea probablemente tengas
un algoritmo para ir de la casa a la
escuela para hacer un sándwich de queso
a la parrilla o para encontrar lo que
quieres comprar en el supermercado en
ciencias de la computación un algoritmo
es un conjunto de pasos para que un
programa de computadora realice una
tarea los algoritmos son la ciencia en
las ciencias de la computación y
encontrar buenos algoritmos y saber
cuándo aplicarlos te permitirá escribir
programas interesantes e importantes
hablemos sobre algunos ejemplos de
algoritmos famosos cómo es que la
aplicación hangouts de google transmite
vídeo en vivo a través de internet tan
rápido usando algoritmos de compresión
de audio y vídeo cómo es que google maps
encuentra la ruta para viajar de dallas
texas a orlando florida para que puedas
llegar a disneyworld utilizando un
algoritmo de búsqueda de ruta cómo es
que pixar colorea un modelo 3d de un
personaje basado en la iluminación de
una habitación virtual
utilizan un algoritmo de renderizado
como la nasa elige organizar los paneles
solares de la estación espacial
internacional y cuándo reorganizar los
con algoritmos de planificación y
optimización esos algoritmos son más
complejos que nuestros algoritmos de
cada día cómo hacer un sándwich de queso
a la parrilla pero todos ellos se
reducen a lo mismo una serie de pasos
para realizar una tarea si conoces algo
sobre algoritmos existentes puedes
ahorrarte un poco de esfuerzo y hacer
tus programas más rápidos aplicando el
algoritmo correcto por ejemplo digamos
que estás escribiendo un juego y que
quieres que el usuario pueda jugar en
contra de la computadora bueno podrías
mirar el juego de damas para inspirarte
los científicos en computación han
encontrado cómo escribir programas del
juego de damas que nunca pierden usando
el algoritmo de búsqueda minimax que
busca dentro del enorme árbol de todos
los movimientos posibles si tu juego es
similar al de damas entonces podrías
usar algoritmos basados en estas
técnicas si no es así entonces conocer
las limitaciones
esos algoritmos podrían conducir te a
rediseñar tu juego si es que se requiere
un jugador experto también es importante
saber cómo diseñar nuevos algoritmos así
como aprender cómo analizar su exactitud
y eficiencia en las ciencias biológicas
se diseñan nuevos algoritmos
continuamente para propósitos tales como
el diseño de las estructuras moleculares
que son el núcleo de medicamentos para
combatir enfermedades en física los
algoritmos simulan patrones climáticos y
meteorológicos y otros algoritmos buscan
y analizan la gran cantidad de datos
sobre estrellas en el universo que son
recolectados por telescopios espaciales
automatizados en todas las ciencias e
incluso en sitios web como kant academy
se necesitan algoritmos eficientes para
analizar enormes conjuntos de datos o
para seleccionar inteligentemente de una
gran cantidad de posibles decisiones en
casi cualquier área en la que pudieras
estar interesado nuevos algoritmos
permitirán aprovechar el poder
computacional masivo para hacer cosas
que la gente realmente necesita y por
las cuales
ahora no todos los algoritmos son
creados igualmente entonces que hace que
un algoritmo sea bueno los dos criterios
más importantes son que resuelva el
problema que nos ocupa y que lo haga
eficientemente la mayoría de las veces
queremos un algoritmo que nos dé una
respuesta que sabemos que siempre es
correcta
algunas veces podemos vivir con un
algoritmo que no nos dé una respuesta
exacta o la mejor respuesta porque los
únicos algoritmos perfectos que
conocemos para resolver esos problemas
en realidad toman mucho tiempo por
ejemplo digamos que queremos un programa
que determine la ruta más eficiente para
un camión que entrega paquetes empezando
y terminando el día en el almacén
tomaría semanas ejecutarlo y examinar
todas las posibilidades pero si nos
parece bien tener un programa que
determine una ruta que es buena pero que
probablemente no sea la mejor entonces
eso podría ejecutarse en segundos en
algunos casos bueno es suficiente como
mires la eficiencia de un algoritmo
podríamos cronometrar cuánto tarda
físicamente
ejecutarse el código pero eso sólo nos
daría información sobre esa
implementación en particular en un
cierto lenguaje de programación en una
determinada computadora y solo para la
entrada que se le dio en cambio los
científicos en computación usan una
técnica llamada análisis asintóticos que
permite comparar algoritmos
independientemente del lenguaje de
programación particular o del hardware
de modo que podamos decir de manera
concluyente que si algunos algoritmos
son más eficientes que otros ahora
puedes aprender sobre algoritmos y sobre
análisis a sintético en khan academy
gracias a la contribución de dos
profesores de la universidad de darmouth
don carmen es el primer autor del libro
de texto universitario sobre algoritmos
más popular del mundo además es el autor
de algoritmos un log cabin balcón diseño
el curso de introducción acs e
investigación robótica en darmouth él
construyó el primer robot el mundo que
pliega origami
tómate 20 enseñarás muchos de los
algoritmos que deberías aprender en la p
ss ss 101 como algoritmos de búsqueda de
reordenamiento recursivos y mi favorito
algoritmos de grafos habrá muchísimas
visualizaciones interactivas
cuestionarios y desafíos de programación
que te ayudarán a entender mejor a lo
largo de tu viaje de aprendizaje